I feel like when a kid dreams about
being rich this is what he imagines and
I get rich I'm gonna move in New York
City any crepe with Cheetos
well [ __ ] we're doing it what's
up guys I'm Clark I'm Michelle and we
are here at the spotted cheetah a
special Cheetos pop-up restaurant in New
York City it's a three-day pop-up
happening right here in Tribeca and
they're basically serving food all made
with Cheetos and apparently the wait
list is up to a thousand people deep
well completely booked up and apparently
they filled up within the first six
hours of opening reservations let's go
check it out when you walk in the door
you agree with it's like like dumb but
awesome like cheeto cheeto inspired art
cheeto inspired cocktail when I was
creating the recipes I was thinking
about all the flavor profiles that are
involved not just regular cheesy Cheetos
there's crunchy there's puffy there's
flamin hot there's flaming hot chocolate
lay they're slinging hot jalapeno
there's all kinds of stuff and who knew
that there was sweet O's desert Cheetos
I was trying to think about how many
different ways and how many different
types of Cheetos that I can use and how
could I be creative and fun and also
delicious is the first official taste
says hey grilled cheese and tomato sauce
that's cheesy it's tasty it's really
good I mean it just tastes with a mohawk
little cheese which I mean I think
that's that's the goals you don't want
something to taste like Oh
way to cheat oh you like you want the
the flavors definitely go look at that
beauty flamin hot cheeto white cheddar
mac and cheese and smell the flamin hot
like I just cleared up my nostrils with
that I'm really excited knowing that
does it's gonna be like a little bit
sitebeam mostly cuz I'm like the type of
person who like add hot sauce to
everything so let me know it's gonna be
good Hey Cheetos yeah so my just like
white cheddar she goes inside and then
they chip away for Lady hot on top
absolutely yeah and as a kid like I
would put chips and cheetos on my
sandwiches right so putting them in the
grilled cheese it's like a nostalgic
glass of the past early that's why I did
now we're gonna try the Cheetos beef
veal pork meatball I would have never
thought she doesn't feel go together but
let's get fancy as hell let me see him I
just love you like day into the bag for
together you like you to meet-- ball on
the end of a fork and just ran it to the
bottom of the cheeto
I think the best part is that like the
Cheetos is in the main ingredient so
it's not like gross and weird it's like
another like spice so these are the
fried green tomatoes and they're
basically made with the Cheetos breading
Bon Appetit again it's really good
mostly because I like fried everything
yeah these are the Lamone hot cheetos
tacos and as you can see they are filled
with crunchy spicy hot cheetos and I
think sour cream you can understood a
couple flamin hot cheetos from here go
so this tastes like la I grew up on a
middle-school diet of hot cheetos
and Mexican food that's this you just
found out this is our course we got
cookies I think it would get Apple
creeps
these are both baked or somehow infused
with sweet oh let's try the sweet and
salty cookie I'm different mine and some
caramel that's good I like this one
because it actually is working with the
cheeto on it we got the white cheddar
cheeto
it takes a bull - chef to try and infuse
the desert with Cheetos like that's a
savory sweet dynamic I'm looking for
with the cheeto sweet and it's carbine
is cheesy so I would be lying if I said
this wasn't tasty we should polish off
with these now let's do the great thing
about this meal no cheeto dust app yeah
all the joy of Cheetos but none of the
guilt
I am cheese and I am happy that was a
flamin hot meal like it could be easily
could be cheesy but it was classy
yeah chester the cheeto yeah she knows
how to run a nice joint
[Music]